[Music]
my name is saba khan and i'm a member of
the stanford mba admissions staff
and we're all so excited to welcome you
here today to a session that we're
calling profiles in resilience
and this session is going to be led
by one of our wonderful faculty members
professor
huggie rau who is a professor of
organizational behavior
here at stanford he's also the author of
scaling up excellence which is a wall
street journal bestseller
we're also joined by a couple of folks
who helped us create the case
that you were sent ahead of time that
hopefully you all had to take a look at
had a chance to take a look at as your
so-called homework
prior to this session and those two
people that are joining us include
olivia hollisi who's one of our students
at the undergraduate at stanford
university
and also justin willow who is a member
of our instructional media staff
so with all of that said i want to
welcome professor huggy rau
in leading this session today and we'll
have a chance to interact with you all
as you get settled in via the q a box
and again
welcome and we hope that you enjoy
today's session for the next 60 minutes
or so
thank you so very much saba for the
gracious and generous introduction
good evening everybody greetings from
stanford california
we're deeply grateful all of you are
taking the time to be with us
this evening and be very privileged to
serve you
what i thought i'd do is to actually
share a few ideas with you to stimulate
you
and then saba and a number of our other
colleagues
will actually get into conversation mode
to actually discuss
hopefully the case study some if not all
of you have had a chance to look through
and that is the case study called uh
making people bigger and better
about cynthia bergs the chief people
officer
at uh genentech but first
let me share my screen and tee up a
couple of ideas for us
to think about this evening
so the topic actually is about
realizing your possible self
i realize you're pursuing an mba or are
interested in an mba and of course many
of us think of an mba program as
a venue to acquire skills others think
of it as a credential
but what i'm urging you to think about
is think of it as a place where
or an opportunity for you to realize
your
possible self let me actually
begin with the starting premise
so most of us in our daily lives what do
we do we rely on comparison shopping
when we choose among products jobs or
for that matter business schools
and in comparison shopping what do we do
we assemble the data
about the key attributes of the product
job or school
and essentially create a matrix to
compare them
i wonder whether such comparison
shopping is a decoy
one that lures us to address a simple
problem in order to tame
a far bigger question and the far bigger
question for me is
which version of yourself are you
choosing
when you pick one job over another one
school over another that's what i want
you to
actually think about often
what we see as product choices
school choices job choices
particularly they all are choices
amongst competing versions of
ourselves but i'm sure a number of you
are saying
of course timing matters doesn't the
current
pandemic the covet crisis
shape this process my short answer is of
course
and here i want to point out to you
crises are both threats and
opportunities
it's easy to think of a crisis as a
threat
and not as an opportunity and let me
give you a simple instance
several months ago i was talking with a
senior bain
consultant who was actually trying to
understand what happened in world war
ii and he came upon a very interesting
contrast between
coke and hershey at the end of world war
ii
coke was everywhere because it was part
of a gi spa backpack
and coke looked at themselves and said
hey we're a global company
but so was hershey's hershey's too was
in every gi's backpack
but after the war world war ii was over
they said hey we supported our troops
time to get back to hershey pennsylvania
and they were no longer a global brand
even though they could have been
so crisis is an opportunity is a threat
and this is at the individual level too
and i want to
give a shout out to somebody who might
get to class called
sahil lavinia and one of the interesting
things
this young man did was at the age of 19
he got five million dollars from
kleiner perkins to start his fund
unfortunately his fund didn't ramp up
at the 30 growth rate and as he said if
i wasn't ready for series a
he found it very difficult he actually
got into a science fiction workshop
in utah changed his religion married and
today runs a company
where which is not as big but as he
points out he makes a healthy amount of
money
but only works 20 hours a week and
that's his promise
to all the employees he employs he said
do you want to get a lot more money at
facebook and work all the time
or do you want to work from me get paid
100 grand for working 20 hours a week
and
it's amazing how many take takers are
there
but the problem is when we see crises as
threats we're in a room called
fear and the natural question is how can
you
imagine your possible self when you're
in a room called fear
you need to go to a room called hope in
order to think about your possible self
what does fear do we all know fear
creates tunnel vision
risk aversion we choose the familiar
what about hope
we're a lot more open we take lot more
risks
so we need a passageway to get from the
room called
fear to a room called hope and this
evening
my suggestion to you is that a
passageways
possible selves and in particular
as i describe in a moment your best
self are possible sounds
i imagine all of you on this call
you're all thinking of your possible
selves what
might i become what would i like to
become what am i afraid of becoming
so possible selves create a link between
what we think and what we do
cognition and motivation so in a lovely
experiment that was done
you know they randomly took undergrads
put them randomly into two groups
in one control group undergrads went and
saw a picture of themselves in the
mirror
and they were asked if we gave you ten
thousand dollars what would you do and
predictably
most of them choose vacation someplace
else
in the treatment condition again a
randomly picked group of undergrads
walked in
they saw pictures of themselves in a
mirror but this time the pictures were
all
age enhanced i was a
20 year old undergrad i saw myself with
flecks of gray as a 50 year old person
and then the undergrads were asked what
would you do with 10 grand
immediately it was all about 401ks and
savings and so on so forth
you can imagine just stimulating oneself
over another
led to a different choice so
what i want to do is to suggest that you
think about your best self
what's your best self all of us in our
lives
we've had defining moments moments
when we felt that our very essence was
brought to light
and the idea behind the best self as
coco chanel put it is
how many cares one loses when one
decides not to be
something but instead be someone
how do we get in touch with our best
self very simple
you can ask yourself what are the three
words that describe you as an individual
what's unique about you that leads to
your happiest times of performance best
performance at work
and most of all a personal highlights
reel
reflect upon a time it might be when you
were an intern when you were working
when you were at home
when you were at college wherever where
you felt that you were acting the way
you were born to act
you felt your very essence was being
reflected
that is really your best self and really
our challenge is how can we repeat the
behavior in your role
in your current job or for that matter
in your school
and that's what we want you to actually
think about
but first is there any evidence the best
self
works here's a field experiment that
means
an experiment where people were randomly
assigned into control
and treatment conditions in the real
world it was in an indian company called
wipro
and it was done by two people dan cable
and francisco
what did they do wipro hired so many
people
one group of people were randomly put
through regular onboarding
another group was given the best self
exercise
they were told prepare your personal
highlights reel
excuse me introduce yourself to your
teammates
another group was called the
organizational identity group
a top manager of wipro spoke about wipro
they got a star performer at wipro to
describe
how wipro helped him or her to be a star
performer
and later they looked at the engagement
of employees the errors they committed
and the quit rate who did best
people who actually wrote about their
best self and thought about
creating it in their job were more
engaged
they actually performed better in their
job with fewer errors and mistakes
and they also quit at a much lower rate
helping the company and obviously
themselves
now i also wanted to share with you a
little experiment that we did
at stanford gsb after coving what
happened to our students our mba and msx
students
many of them were in a room called fear
they needed to
go to a room called hope what did we
think about
we actually thought hey the alumni are
the passageway
they will take our mba students and ms
excers
from the room called fear to a room
called hope we began with a pilot with
30 students
our alumni came up with the name what's
the name of the initiative
you will never walk alone it's the name
of a song as some of you recall
it's a song that liverpool the soccer
club uses
so what did we do we took we began a
pilot with 30 alums and 30 students
we asked each student don't send a vita
or your linkedin page to the alum
they'll judge you we don't want anybody
to judge you
we want them to understand you create a
two-minute video using your cell phone
about your best self but if you're an
alarm you're also confused about how to
help the student
do they want a job do they want a
shoulder what is it that they need
and we asked the alums to send the mba
and msxers
a two-minute video of their best self
helping somebody
30 people met for three four
conversations it worked well
right now we're scaling it to 100 mbas
msxs and alums and eventually
we'll scale it to everybody i wanted to
give you an except for one from one of
our students who actually met her mentor
and that's what she said she says i met
with my you'll never walk alone mentor
yesterday
and wanted to let you know it was the
most honest conversation
i've had with any gsb alum he was
incredibly thoughtful and open about his
life
the failures successes and what he would
do a second time around
the honesty and vulnerability in the
conversation mirrored
no other alumni conversation i've had it
was incredibly refreshing to hear from
someone
without rose tinted classes and you can
imagine
what the value of that conversation is
uh and where do i want to close
i want to close on a simple note as
you're thinking of stanford gsb
ask yourself which version of yourself
are you choosing
you're not choosing one school over
another
ask yourself which version of yourself
are you
choosing over another and
think of a new psychological contract
when you come to gsb what is it we
expect of you
you bring your best self to school
and work here and life here and what
does gsb do in return
we it's not the employee but the student
we actually help you realize
your best self through a variety of
courses
and the like and the idea is courses are
all opportunities
not just to recruit and activate your
best self
but to extend it to enhance it to enrich
it
and remember when you the final point i
want to make
when you think of stanford gsb is please
think of us
not as a destination but instead a place
where you begin your journey
of recruiting your uh best self
and extending and enriching it that's
what i wanted to say
just as a way to for you to reflect a
little bit
and i want to turn things over to saba
so we can have a conversation
and then hopefully channel the case
study about cynthia burks
where presumably you had the chance to
see how she cultivated her best self
and how she actually recruited it to her
role
as chief people officer at genentech
take it away saba and i'm going to stop
sharing the screen
right now perfect
wonderful huggy that was such a
fantastic
groundwork that you set for all of us as
we start to think about
takeaways and learnings from the case
that you've all had a chance to take a
look at
so many of you if you're still exploring
whether to mba or not to mba are
probably
encountering that the hallmark of many
business schools
is a a case method teaching method
and not all classes at the gsb are
taught with the case method
but typically in your core curriculum in
your first couple of quarters at the gsb
you will unpack over 200 business cases
and this case in particular
um is very special for many reasons
and i would just love to hear from you
huggie about the inspiration for this
case
and a little bit about how you use the
case method
thank you uh saba please use the q a
option to
write and share comments about whatever
i've spoken thank you erica
happy that those insights were helpful
so
let me respond to saba's question about
the case method
i would say the way we think of teaching
and learning at the stanford business
school is
we think of it as a mix of two things
clean models from the world of theory
and research
and dirty hands from the real world
so pretty much in every class we like to
combine
clean models with dirty hands how do we
do that
the clean models are supplied by the
professors who do research experiments
all of that what about the dirty hands
we might actually get
a couple of corporate guests we might
get you to go and do a project in a
company
but the other way we get dirty hands
into the classroom is
we use a case study case studies are of
two types
one case one type of case studies it's a
demonstration case
like today's case study it doesn't have
a problem for you to actually
think about it's a demonstration it's an
example if you will
as to one person and what we want to do
in the case study method is
take in this case cynthia one particular
person
can we actually do induction that is go
from the very particular case of one
individual to a more general conclusion
other kinds of case studies we have we
they usually involve
uncertainties and problems you might
have to calculate market size
you might have to anticipate what
competitors do you might have to think
about what price
you're going to price your product at
all of those things for that
you need to do pre-work and hopefully
you will also engage in
argument and debate and discussion in
the classroom
so what is the case study the case study
is a way to give you incomplete
information
to get you to generate hypotheses on the
basis of incomplete information
and then to see if we can actually
extract
something from the case study so that's
the real opportunity for the case study
but today we're actually going to
discuss
or examine or take advantage of
not a problem-oriented case study but
actually instead of demonstration case
study
instead a demonstration of how cynthia
burgs
got in touch with her best self and how
she constructed
a future for herself with her best self
kush soda has an observation here kush
says i like the room of fear to
aromaphobe
and i wonder if it applies to layoffs
these are exactly the kinds of questions
people will actually bring up
in the case study for example had we had
a case study and layoffs
the short answer kush is yes indeed
most companies don't know how to manage
layoffs
and there indeed are better ways of
creating passageways
from a room called fear to a room called
hope
one idea that we're working on at the
stanford business school along with a
couple of colleagues
is why can't employees and firms have
learning budgets
each company question your company your
company can allocate
a training budget to every individual
employee
you accumulated for three four years in
the unfortunate event of a layoff or you
being asked to leave
you can carry your learning budget with
you to acquire new skills
you can't pay yourself so that's an
example of going from a room called fear
to a room called hope
so please continue to use the q a option
that was a slightly long response to
your query sabha
so other questions kind of comments
i'm happy to join in
that was a wonderful outline we have
another question
um coming in from angela
who says besides a room called fear and
a room called hope are there other rooms
that organizations or individuals need
to move from
such as stagnation or
yeah that's actually a very nice
question uh
angelia the short answer is yes
so for example you know if you're an
organization that's poorly performing or
you're part of an organization
that's poorly for performing chances are
that you might be in a room called
resignation
if on the other hand you're an
organization that's doing well as you
quite correctly imply you might be in a
room called
complacency or comfort so we got to get
you out of those rooms
and either get you to a room called
aggression or a room called
pride
so the short on the room metaphor is a
helpful idea
and the reason it's helpful for me and
the reason it should be helpful for
us is we actually think of ourselves
a little more systematically and we
think of the other person's
journey not what we want to do
which is the reason why we're actually
having this session
so that you can move all of you
listening in today can move from your
room of doubt because i'm sure
some of you are wondering you know is
gsb the place for me do i fit in do i
belong here
a variety of questions like that and we
wanted to make sure you had an
opportunity
to move to the room called hope and
that's why we thought the cynthia
burke's case study prepared by
justin and his team from instructional
design
and olivia a wonderful
undergrad student at stanford hopefully
you'll all get a sense of what that is
about
so please feel free to comment on the
case study
think of cynthia burks because i can
tell you
i learnt a lot when i was interviewing
cynthia
as i'm sure olivia did and justin did
and
saba did so there are other questions as
well
saba take it away yeah there are a
couple of questions
i actually wanted to interject and
anchor us a little bit back in the case
one of the questions that is related to
this entire discussion that you posed to
cynthia
was to describe her job
in a four-letter word and i'm wondering
um how that exercise came about and then
if you want to think about that exercise
for our
attendees or our participants what you
would pose to them
great question sabha so you know all of
us have
like job descriptions and they're hugely
long
and you know they can be kind of tedious
to listen to i imagine
i can see justin nodding his head
instead what i thought was
the way i began with cynthia was i said
describe your job using a faux letter
word and i was thinking she was going to
use
something having to do with actions and
then
i actually thought i could get her to
discover
how did she come upon this job
description or understanding of the job
without me ever using the word best self
that's why i asked her to use a
four-letter word and as you know
what was the faux letter word she chose
she chose a full letter word called help
because that was her best self and where
did she learn help
from the roots of it were from her
childhood
when she went with her dad to the picket
line
when at the age of 25 or 26
she made a decision to adopt the twin
sons of her sister
who was having drug issues and the like
that's what actually activates your best
self
after that even though she hopped from
banking to hr
to whatever it wasn't a big deal for her
why wasn't it a big deal
she wasn't changing industry she was
just getting in touch with her best self
banking wasn't the place where she could
showcase her best self
hr in banking was and that's how it led
to hr and newspapers
and then eventually hr in biotechnology
so what cynthia shows us is
it's funny we always think of
we hear words like develop the brand of
you
develop you as a startup or whatever we
hear all these words but what are they
your brand and you as a startup isn't
what you
sell it's who you are
it's your best self and that's why it's
engaging
i should point out there are a number of
questions on the little talk i gave
saba so just thought i'd mention that to
you so
i'm happy to respond to those questions
anytime you feel that makes sense
yeah absolutely so let's jump into some
of the questions that you have
christina is asking this case seems
especially apropos
[Music]
in light of the uncertainty that's
happening in the current world
cynthia showed her ability to stay open
to changes in her plan
in a variety of situations would love to
hear more about how leaders should work
to cultivate openness to uncertainty and
flexibility to lean into change
yeah there is a lot in there christina
the short answer is your way right
cynthia did actually stay open
to changes in her plan in a variety of
situations
my hope is christina you're going to be
with us on friday
because we have another incredible guest
as well
and she will actually tell you how our
aspirations are linear
but our paths to those goals are
circular
so what that means is my short answer to
you cynthia i mean
christina is
the easy though a simple way to think of
flexibility
and openness is to think of everything
as a journey rather than
as a destination if we think of things
as destinations we become
fixed we don't persist with behavior
if we think of our accomplishments as
or our quests as journeys we do better
let me give you a simple example
so suppose you set yourself let's say a
goal like i want to lose
five pounds of weight suppose i set
myself that goal
a destination model of goals is hey
i i reduced five pounds in weight my
goals accomplished what am i going to do
i'm going to stop trying but on the
other hand
christina if you asked me huggy can you
actually tell me the
journey you went through from being a
couch potato
to being somebody who lost five pounds i
began to think oh my god
i had to level myself off of a couch i
had to walk
i had to do this i had to do that and
you think of all these like little micro
steps that got you to
like losing five pounds am i going to
stop after that
when i see all those incremental actions
now
i'm going to continue with that even
though i've been thrown a curveball
or i've been done something different so
the journey-oriented mindset
is the important thing there are a
number of other questions too sabah i
don't know how you'll
curate them i can quickly
go through them or we can wait at the
end you manage time and tell me what to
do
saba is my boss for this evening
everybody
completely grateful to her no we're all
helping each other out
i'm happy to moderate these questions um
and so i can keep track of what's
answered or not answered we
may not get to all of them so i
apologize in advance if we don't get to
your question but keep them coming these
are
really beautifully written we have one
let me pick a couple of them and i'll
quickly sort of go through some of these
questions require a long answer
okay very thoughtful question
mommy says hey don't you need fear and
hope the short answer is
excellent observation burma you need
both if you're in a room called fear
you run the risk of type 1 error
everything looks like a threat
if you're in a room called hope
everything looks like an opportunity
and as you can imagine that too is a
type one error right not everything
can be an opportunity you need to toggle
back and forth and that's the advantage
of the best self
as you keep questioning yourself
cleo cheng says what exercises can
organizations
do to develop resilience and the ability
to to have hope uh i think is what cleo
asks
cleo the short answer is what i would
recommend that organizations do
is they heavily invest in subtracting
and taking
bs out of the lives of people because
when you work in a real organization
a lot of the work you do is actually a
little bit of bs
and so if we subtract we can actually
save
a lot of time so we've recently written
case studies
where we showed that if you subtract a
lot of subtraction is like mowing the
lawn
as my friend drew houston of dropbox
says
that's the reason you need to subtract
that's the way to actually build that
charlie yates says this is really
beautiful charlie charlie says
thank you for the case study the case
study spoke to me because i built
myself thanks to my mother's dedication
to push my education and creativity
despite being an immigrant
from a low socioeconomic status i think
cynthia's
parents were similarly pivotal have you
seen similar importance of parents
families and mentors charlie uh
thank you for actually teeing that up
you're absolutely spot-on
parents help a lot relatives help a lot
role models help a lot and the reason
they help a lot is they tell you what is
possible
so thank you for tuning that up and
indeed you're blessed that
you've been helped by your parents as
well so
i think uh thank you for that um
there are a number of other questions uh
laura says uh brian says is there a
correlation between
a room called hope and overall happiness
this is a good ques and he says
does happiness lead to hope or hope
leads to happiness
so the thing to keep in mind brian is uh
it's a very good question but we've got
to keep in mind that happiness is a
double-edged sword
we can have happiness but happiness that
inhibits
surge that leads to complacency
that that only leads you to search for
opportunities that
fit you and that don't stretch you
that would be a problem in my view
thomas says what would be the next step
from a hope room
after the hope room is it an action room
yes indeed
[Music]
andrew says are there different
approaches we can take to foster
communities
at work yeah absolutely andrew
you can ask your teammates ask them
choose a job title that showcases their
best self
whatever job title they choose give them
five minutes to think about it
another five minutes to share that might
make
a big difference psy topher says
uh you know what tips do you have for
visualization
great question topher there's a recent
paper written by my colleague nier
halevi in personality and social
psychology bulletin
what did they do in a couple of
experiments
they ask people to think of hierarchies
in one condition they ask
people visualize a hierarchy as a
pyramid
in the other condition they said
visualize the hierarchy as a ladder
where do you think people competed more
it's amazing
the moment you tell the hierarchy is a
ladder it's amazing how much competition
that fosters and what kind of
maladaptive
consequences you can have
um laura says i moved to a room of hope
help your team as i told you laura ask
them to choose their job titles
simple thing to do
you know get people to or ask them hey
what is it that weighs down on you what
is
it that actually takes you to a room
called
fear maybe those are things you can
actually subtract
psy says how can they harness their
failures as a path to success good
question psy
but hopefully when we have more than one
failure they're all trying out different
behaviors
if you try the same behavior and fail
three times
you're repeating the mistake or at least
there's a risk of that
we need to be careful ashna where is she
how do you suggest we make that move in
the
next few months cynthia's move was
through years
yes cynthia took years
that's very true but you don't
necessarily need to take years
you can get in touch with your best self
quicker through this
exercise and that's the point of the
exercise
you can even involve other people to
help you discover
your best self too uh
michael shin says how can you know your
choice
was right michael you're asking a very
thoughtful question
and i think the way i am understanding
your question is
when we make choices this is the way i'm
understanding your question
when we make choices we anticipate
regret
so it's called post decision regret when
you buy something you say geez could
that be a lemon
when you take a job or whatever it is
and the thing you want to sort of
and be mindful about is you want the
post decision regret to be informative
but not the only thing that determines
your choice sarah says
cynthia might be someone who sees the
role of managers or leaders
as ones those who help employees
absolutely sarah
the most effective leaders have the
biggest health
muscle and one of the things hopefully
you will do
at the stanford gsb through a variety of
courses is
you will discover your health muscle
then you will discover not only what
your health muscle is
but how to use it but because remember
great leaders are people who make people
around them better
great leaders reduce the standard
deviation in performance
that's what great leaders do they don't
just perform well themselves
um how am i doing with questions and
time
alicia i like this metaphor it's very
similar to the topic of disequilibrium
yes indeed
it is quite tight to the topic of this
equilibrium
alicia and all that it says is
as you rightly point out you've got to
get comfortable being
uncomfortable this is what i mean by
stretch rather than fit fit
puts you only in comfort stretch allows
you to develop
new muscles and by the way when you
think of our
when you think of gsb don't think of the
mba program as a program
think of it instead as a gym what do we
do in a gym
we work out different muscles that's
what you need to think of doing
when you actually come to gsb uh
other questions uh m uh what is it
emily uh boy thank you emily
uh emily is enrolled she says in a
meditation experience
deepak chopra excellent suggestion
how does our leader transfer hope to
an organization like cynthia's with 13k
employees
you know cynthia i mean emily
i learned this from a ceo
he introduced himself to me and said
haggy i'm the cto in the company and i
said excuse me
how can you be the chief technology
officer because you're called the ceo he
said no i'm the cto
i said hey chris what does cto mean he
said it means chief thank you officer
i can't do anything without the help of
a lot of people i said what do you do
every day
he said every day he said i thank three
people in detail
for their accomplishments in the
organization
three people it leads to three stories
that spread very fast
that's how i build hope he says kush
says are there other four letter words
that's your job kush
think of more four letter words think of
actions
think of words rashmi says
is the best self and evolving uh
sorry zaid says uh is the best self an
evolving state yeah
it's not a destination remember it's a
journey
rashmi says can you speak to how the gsb
pushes students to being uncomfortable
well one simple way rashmi is
you're actually going to be with people
who are very very talented
let me give you my own example when i
moved to the stanford business school
from the kellogg school 16 17 years ago
i s there are ten of us from kellogg who
moved to stanford at various points in
time
and when we moved here we were all a
little apprehensive
most people who joined stanford gsb to
be honest with you are a little
apprehensive because
our faculty has a couple of nobel prize
winners we have two people who won the
nobel prize recently
paul milgram who was an mba student he
was so bright at the end of the first
year they gave him direct admission to
phd
and two years later he finished the phd
the other was his advisor bob wilson
now how can you be a professor amongst
people who won nobel prizes and four
people out of a faculty of hundred
have won baby nobels the answer is you
got to get in touch with your best self
that's when you feel secure and you've
discovered your gift
you're not trying to be somebody you're
not
so hopefully all of that is helping how
am i doing for time
uh uh saba i'm whipping through these
questions quickly
okay you're you're a speed demon and
it's awesome so we've got about
20 minutes left and we have about 30
questions there are a bunch of questions
maybe
i treat questions as gifts so can i take
a stab at a few more as well
please this time is yours and i i really
appreciate the fact that
more questions continue to come in
clearly the answers are really valuable
so daniela you're right so we don't need
to stay flexible
and the way we need to stay flexible is
by taking risks
because see just you know think of it as
scaling a company
we say startup to scale up what's a
scale up
in silicon valley or the bay area
scale-up means doesn't mean doing the
same thing
i once had a senior executive from uber
in my class
daniella and i asked him how long have
you worked in uber
he smiled at me and he said professor
rao i worked in uber for four years
but it feels as though i worked for 16
different
companies what does he mean by that
every quarter uber is a different
company
hundred thousand rides you're one kind
of company quarter million rides you're
another kind of company
it's the same thing as you get to
different levels of responsibility
as you take more risks your fluid self
is certainly going to change a lot
anand ragu says did
cynthia had i found cynthia's study to
be inspirational but did she have any
regrets
uh anything different in cynthia's case
uh anand i didn't think she had any
regrets
remember she was so secure she joined
genentech as a temp as an hr
partner in 10 years she got to the
c-suite
that's a remarkable achievement that's a
remarkable achievement
so what she did was she didn't
allow her personal growth
ambitions to interfere her whole thing
was the more i help people
the bigger will my franchise be and the
bigger will my
remit be and eventually that's what
happened
um alvaro says
what values do we have to put forward to
get the most of ourselves as
human beings alvaro great question
for me i would suggest that you think of
three things
caring sharing and daring
put simply those are the three things
i'd urge you to think about
whom do you care for and why what are
you willing to share for
and why how do you dare and when those
are the things
i'd encourage you to think about
um diego says uh
what um
[Music]
when overcoming adversity or a crisis
how would you suggest we
apply our previous best selves to
overcome the adversity
and improve yourself for the future
great question eric
see overcoming adversity means
resilience
i have to tell you in 19
in the 1950s and 60s when psychologists
began
studying resilience a number of them
were based in minnesota
and coincidentally a number of
psychologists who studied resilience
fought in the battle of the bulge in
world war
ii and if you recall your world war
history that was a moment of resilience
for american troops
they were actually you know hit with a
shock and they recovered
brilliantly so what does resilience mean
the psychologist who studied resilience
the person who led him to study
resilience
was a young 13 year old boy in
minneapolis
minnesota his father was an alcoholic
his mother was dysfunctional cognitively
but yet every single day he came to
school
he came with a clean white shirt clean
blue
shorts a uniform and a
sandwich with two slices of bread with
nothing in between
and the psychologist said how can he
live in a tsunami at home
and come to school every day like that
what is it that makes this person
special
and that's when they came upon the idea
of resilience
of being persistent and indeed it means
getting in touch with your authentic
self um
so there are a couple of questions like
that i'm going to sort of showcase
people who haven't spoken
[Music]
so yajao whether you move from the room
of relativeness to the room of action
depends on a given context yes indeed if
you're a company being acquired it's a
little different for you
than the company acquiring you uh thomas
says what are the main limitations
many limitations of the ones we impose
on ourselves
so lewis raises an interesting point
lewis says
i really liked how cynthia approached
doubt
um so and i'm glad you think
approaching doubt is very very critical
consolata cynthia's case was really
interesting
uh and you raise a good question saying
how did she move from what felt like
falling into things but openly planning
more
so this is a really good question
consolator
most of us think planning is about the
future
actually even though you plan about the
future
the most important consequence of
planning is
it reshapes your attitude to the present
that's the function of planning when you
plan
it's not like you're going to create
your future you approach
the present very differently and indeed
you're right
cynthia did harness that and use that
very well
and julia says what's the role of others
it's not only feedback angelia for me
feedback is
looking in the rearview mirror for me
it's feed
forward to get you through the
windscreen and figure out what you
should do next
so louis cynthia's story really
resonated with me
absolutely cynthia i mean absolutely
louis
and cynthia talks about serving as a
mentor because she saw the power of
mentorship and how do we build these
relationships this is what paying
forward is all about louis
we get health and we pay forward and the
more you do that
and the more you help people the better
you actually become
um
does the idea of
bringing your best self to work mean you
bring your full
full self um you know
the reason i ask is because people are
not comfortable
bringing the full self due to fear of
losing the demeanor
of respect from co-workers due to
difference in cultural or socio-economic
backgrounds
thank you ibhadi for asking this
question
the way i hear you saying this is you're
saying
people suppress some parts of themselves
because they don't know how it will be
received
and they're worried about being judged
and i certainly understand
that all i'm saying is and this is one
of the challenges
of the journey at gsb hopefully you'll
realize
as you build your own network of friends
and peers and so on
there'll be many micros safe spaces
where you can actually bring
more of yourself because we whether we
like it or not
we bring a lot of ourselves to our work
without question
so suppressing it takes effort it
actually distracts
it's also very burdensome i should tell
you there's nothing being ashamed about
it
let me give you a personal example ibade
when i came to america
as a phd student in 1983 i could tell
you about the supreme court the u.s
constitution
the politics of america i could tell you
all of that
i didn't know how to in those days make
a collect call using a public phone
it wasn't available in india i didn't
know how to do that
i didn't even know who a panhandler was
so they didn't look like panhandlers in
the country where i came from
so there are a lot of things you learn
and it's okay and your friends are the
ones who help
i should tell you the friends who helped
me and
my wife and i are now the god parents
for their children
so life has a strange way of taking
things
uh amy cow says how do you establish a
culture of bringing your best self
and accepting other best selves
within a company this is what designing
a job or a role for a colleague is
um amy what's the jobs response what is
the boss's responsibility
i'll give you opportunities for you to
bring your best self
that's the boss's responsibility what's
your responsibility
you bring your best self and so do your
teammates do
matia d alessandra says if religion is
part of my perception of
my best self how much shall we talk of
it
spiritual vocation is only partially
explainable with logic
i certainly understand the question
mattia my view is you know
since you're raising the question of
spiritual vocation
i'm actually reminded
of a very very famous french philosopher
called paul recur
paul recur actually came up with the
idea of what he called
the circle of belief basically what he
said was
if you really want to understand
somebody
you believe in them and then trust them
or you trust them and believe in them
there are two ways of getting there so
you just have to choose your route
and what i hear you saying is believe
first and then trust
or trust first and then believe both of
those are entry points
so for me certainly religion or
any other thing that we do certainly is
and ought to be part of our best self
uh chris calendar
[Music]
says beth berger stand for gsb alum
introduced the concept of sponsoring
change
by looking back to find people unlike
ourselves to sponsor
um yes uh great point chris
going to people unlike ourselves
obviously sort of stretches us
uh do you have advice on how to approach
people
uh that may be in a room called room of
fear
and get them to a room called hope ask
them how can i be of help
that's the simplest question to ask you
don't need to do any complicated
diagnosis
nothing just ask him how can i actually
help
and if you do that people will actually
welcome you
so ask people sort of simple questions
hey what's troubling you today you seem
a little uncomfortable
or you can begin by saying i feel
uncomfortable today
thereby giving somebody implicit moral
permission
to do the same thing jordan says
how does having employees uh bring their
best self correlate with
the profits of a company jordan uh in
experiments we've done
whenever we've asked people to bring
their best self to work they outperform
when you think about profits of a
company that's a difficult question to
answer
and here's why because more profitable
companies are going to make it more
easier for people
to get in touch with their best self and
therefore they're able to do it better
if you're a poorly performing company
sometimes
executives have what's called a zero-sum
mindset
if i do this i can't do that and if you
ask them to devote time to getting the
best self and so
forth they may say it's a distraction
and under invest in it
so your question therefore
is a little more complicated because we
can't actually do an experiment
but generally in experiments we find
that it has a big effect
um kai says cynthia has a simple
philosophy
it is simple but it's also profound kai
so that's the important thing to keep in
mind and you say does it apply to
everyone
should we always make short long term
plan for ourselves
or stay open and try whatever is
interesting
all i'm sort of suggesting is think of
plants as a
pointing finger your plants are fingers
so look at the direction they point
don't latch onto your finger in your
case the plan
so the plant's purpose is to point and
not for you to fixate
um huggy i just want to let you know we
have about
five minutes left
i know we probably have time you're
kidding me with gifts everybody
i'm trying my best to do uh things
ryan asks a good question ryan says how
would you encourage using this framework
to deal with the impostor syndrome the
impostor syndrome is a very valid thing
where people say oh my god
i'm not really good i'm actually
terrible i'm like
faking it and they think i'm making it
and etc
my sort of point is
articulating the fear is the first step
to liberate
yourself from it the more you keep it a
secret the more it drives you
the best way to actually get rid of it
is articulate it
so there are lot more questions so
cynthia i've been like going through
these questions one after another
so since there are a few minutes left
you take the authority and you curl a
couple of questions or you ask me
to talk about some other things that you
feel we should cover
and not be covered i want to thank
everybody for these questions
i wish i had more time to answer them
but hopefully we've made a dent in a few
if not all of them thank you
so much for that herculean effort huggy
i think that was a really impressive uh
sprint and marathon all in one so
um i just want to echo some of the
things that you said
um which is really just to thank
everyone so much for taking the time
to join us today and this is really
intended to be
one really small way that you can get to
experience
what the gsb is all about which is these
rich conversations
the access to our faculty and each other
i hope you enjoyed being able to hear
each other's questions
and um i really want to thank you
professor rau
and also olivia and justin so much for
putting together
this really rich case that i think has
given people
really wonderful food for thought and an
opportunity to reflect
on their own journey from one room to
another and how
how those affect all of us and how that
can be really emblematic
in in the leadership journeys of someone
like cynthia
um so i don't have any closing thoughts
but would love for you professor rau to
close us out
and with some brilliant words of wisdom
and i just want to say thank you again
to everyone who joined us today
and you'll have the opportunity to join
professor rao again on friday if you
haven't signed up for that session
highly recommend it and our case
protagonist will also be there on that
yeah i'll be interviewing the case
protagonist that day
i think on cow summarized it very nicely
as ann puts it it's been amazing to hear
everyone's questions and thoughts
i think that's the best part about
getting a case study exactly right
and so what you've heard and this is the
whole point of a case study
the case studies essentially organize
crowdsourcing to a problem or organize
crowdsourcing to understanding
in this case somebody's life very well
said
um and i think
the thing to sort of point out is
again i want to go back with the core
thing as you look at business schools
as you look at what you're doing
remember
you're not choosing a product you're
choosing a version of yourself
and when you're choosing a version of
yourself
make sure you're bringing your best self
to work if that's what you're thinking
of school
if that's what you're thinking of home
whatever it is
you know people talk getting your a game
getting your a game
is actually getting your best self to
work and that's the line i which i want
to close on
and should any of you join us on friday
you'll actually listen to kay foster
who's another amazing person and you
will see
how she began beginning as a person who
came to america
cleaning rooms in new york at the age of
19.
and then eventually ascending to the
corporate executive suite in jnj
and now she's on a gazillion boards
she calls her journey from the toilet to
the tower
so join me in actually talking to s
k foster on friday and we'll all be
there as well but in the meantime
think about your best self good luck and
[Music]
godspeed